you know how we started and we said the
key thing here is just just work out
what a B and C are okay work out what a
B and C and then you just slide them in
and they're all just sort of unfolds
from there okay
a common mistake students make is that
when they see something like this if it
isn't in the right order they get a B
and C wrong let me show you what I mean
it's very easy to rearrange this I could
have written it for example as 2x plus
3x squared equals 2 these are the same
equation okay however they don't look
the same so a lot of students will look
at this and they'll say oh well I'm
looking for a B and C and they'll just
look at them in order they'll say I'll
make that a that B and that's C okay so
this is wrong for two reasons for
starters let's have a look at a what
makes a a and the answer is it's
attached to X square do you see that
right the coefficient attached to x
squared that a it's not just the one
that happens to be first on the line
okay because we can rearrange these
however we like secondly have a look at
C great what makes C see it's by itself
it's what we call the constant which is
convenient like it's the third letter of
the alphabet that's why it's C but C
also stands for constant in this case
now over there C is a constant look at
it it's got two x's or anything like
that but it's not the real value of C
why not it's in the wrong position you
see this guy here which we call general
form everything's on the left and
there's a zero on the right hand side
well I don't have a zero on the right
hand side here so what I'd have to do is
I have to turn this into this I'd
rewrite it that's what I would do if I
were given this question and you in fact
have been given some of these in the
exercise my first job is rewrite it
properly let's get everything in the
right spot and in the right order and
then you can use the formula okay that's
the first thing everyone needs to know
the second thing everyone is the day is
when you get to this point here suppose
you get to your answer - whatever plus
or minus whatever okay am I done okay
so I want you to write the follow
three phrases underneath this altar here
back and you're working okay the three
phrases are served for exact form and
approximate these three phrases come up
and we need to know what they mean and
which one refers to what third forms
easy to identify because serve four
means you've got Serbs in there right is
this third form this is so fun look it's
got the square root of seven there
there's the third so it's easier to know
this is surd form I've done okay exact
form actually is another way of saying
the same thing because what I've done is
this is the exact precise answer I
haven't like rounded off to any number
of decimal places or anything like that
however sometimes that is exactly what
they want you to do they're like I don't
know what this number is I need to put
it like on a set of axes and I need to
know is this like bigger than three or
more than three where does it go okay so
what you have to do is go to your
calculator and you'd have to put in
minus 1 minus root seven on three you'd
have to input that and you'll get a
decimal out okay then you also have to
put in minus one plus root seven on
three that will give you another decimal
and then you have to approximate both of
them okay so just look carefully at what
the question says like what way do they
want this in and then do it accordingly
okay all right so those are the two
things I wanted everyone to hear I'm now
going to show anyone who's interested
where this monstrous thing comes from
you don't need to know this but the tax
will just show you there's like a little
exercise that unpacks it for you and I
think some of you should actually see
where it comes from because it's a
really important mental exercise so if
you don't know want to know where it
comes from just keep on going with your
questions but do that quietly if you do
want to know where it comes from then I
make a little subheading which is
deriving the formula
um it's gonna need like seven or eight
lines are you watching on or you then
let everyone else pay attention thank
you
so here's my little subheading deriving
the formula before I said that the
quadratic formula and completing the
square actually very similar to each
other okay and you can use them in
exactly the same cases here's why the
quadratic formula comes from completing
the square okay so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna take this guy here okay
are you watching because you don't have
to then let other people just saying I'm
going to take this ax squared plus BX
business and I'm going to complete the
square on it okay but it's not easy
that's why the quadratic formula ends up
looking a bit like a mess okay here's
the first thing I'm going to do all the
times we completed this square we were
doing them with monic quadratics monic
quadratics so you have to turn this
thing into and monic quadratic which I
don't know what it is at the moment okay
so in order to make a one at the front
the first thing I have to do is I have
to divide everything everything by a
does that make sense because you can see
then this won't be some random number
it'll become one right so here's what my
next line looks like the first the x
squared turns into x squared these turns
into fractions it's a bit messy I know
but that's why this is the reason why
the quadratic formula is a fraction
because of this step okay then the next
thing I want to do is I have to do this
completing the square business which
comes from this number here okay go back
to an example of where we completed the
square you remember we were always
paying attention to the coefficient of x
I don't need this guy so I'm gonna kick
it over here
okay I've subtracted it from both sides
what do I add when I complete the square
what I add is I take this number and I
do two things what are two things I have
and then I square I have a middle square
so the first thing we're going to do is
I'm going to have it half of that is B
on to a yeah you see how I've divided by
two so that's why there's a tune but you
don't just have it you also square it so
it's B on to a or squared if you add it
to the left you'd better add it to the
right okay now you'll you'll look at
this in you're like oh wow this is this
is getting pretty tough well yes the
quadratic formula does all of this work
for you by the way you do have the
quadratic formula underneath the square
root it's got to be squared in it this
is what has a B squared because it's
from completing the square
okay now what can I do well this left
hand side is now square at least that's
why I added this thing right
what's it the square of and the answer
is X plus B on to a if you take this
thing Square and you expand it you will
land back on this line okay on the right
hand side I've got a bit of a mess over
here so I need to tidy this up this is
minus C on a what's this thing when I
actually square it out what happens to
the numerator it's gonna be B squared so
that's that denominator it's gonna be 2a
times 2a watch the Vista 2 as well so
this is 4a squared
is that alright now I have two fractions
over here so to simplify this my
instinct is to combine them into one
fraction so to do that I'm gonna need a
common denominator right I'm gonna need
a common area
see I've got 4a squared here I can turn
this into a 4a squared as well by
multiplying it by something what should
i multiply by 4a nailed it so if I
multiply this by 4a it turns into 4a
squared if you did the bottom of the
fraction I guess we better do the top so
this is going to become minus 4ac okay
so now I can combine the two fractions
on the right hand side and now this
should be something familiar look B
squared minus 4ac that's where it came
from okay
and it's all over 4a squared all right
now we've got a lot of the pieces we
recognize but we're still not quite
there yet once you complete the square
you're like I don't want it square I
just want X by itself so I'm going to
take the square root both sides that
leaves you with this on the left hand
side and what on the right hand side
plus or minus the square root of b
squared minus 4ac now that thing is 2a
when you take the square root so
actually I'm just going to do that now
there's one step left but I think you
could probably handle it on your own the
last step is the quadratic formula okay